it's great to take phone calls 617 830
for 750 I think we have time for maybe
one or two more calls who's on the phone
with me next hey dude this is a Anthony
I'm calling from California pleasure to
speak to you what's on your mind well I
kinda have an interesting proposal for
you or maybe just a question okay you
know here in the political spectrum
right now we're seeing something that we
haven't seen for a long time which is
kind of a political realignment where
the rich and the wealthy are going more
towards the democratic party now ever
then they have towards the Republican
Party and what's I based on haven't I
haven't read that what are you basing
that on are you familiar with a secular
talk yes I know Kyle uh he actually
introduced a study that said that uh
were actually the Democratic Party right
now based on current polls and
statistics I can't fight anything
obviously but he's saying that we're
actually getting the uh i think it was
the hundred thousand-plus income for of
white americans now more than ever in
actually over Republicans God's working
I haven't seen that but let's let's
assume that that's the case and and that
way we can you know sort of dig into the
question exactly and the question being
do you think that a donald trump
presidency would really put the nail in
the coffin towards this kind of
draconian you know Republican you know
Yura that we've seen over the last maybe
50 60 years and really kind of you know
make that party kind of become maybe a
little bit more progressive and kind of
take the political alignment from this
you know really Republic
can you know right base where you have
you know so-called progressives like
Hillary Clinton or Barack Obama or
really you know moderate maybe centrist
Republicans yeah and get Carly I think
we're your there's a few issues that
you're sort of mixing together here I
think they all need to sort of be
handled separately and it's probably a
longer discussion I on the question of
the Trump impact on a Republican lip
realignment I think if Trump wins there
will be somewhat of a realignment in
that Republicans who want to play ball
and be part of the inner circle of
President Donald Trump will have to move
on some issues in order to be taken
seriously by Donald Trump because he's
certainly an unconventional Republican
to the extent that he is one at all if
Donald Trump loses there may also be a
Republican realignment but it could go
in either direction it could be
Republicans saying you know some of
trumps less conservative leanings on
some issues that was a disaster for us
in 2016 we're going to move harder right
and push out all the moderates or they
might say Trump lost fine but let's
really rethink now that he's shaken up
our party let's rethink what type of
candidate we want for 2012 and maybe
that means a more moderate candidate on
some issues I don't know the answer I
think we're gonna have to wait until
november eighth to see uh very
interesting question and i really do
appreciate the call from you